Now we're almost home free.
So the first thing I want to point
out is that we can reintroduce these
absolute value signs without
killing anything, because we can.
This was a positive quantity and so
taking the absolute
value doesn't change it.
So the last little thing to point out
is it if we take the max of this same
quantities substituting in different
values of a, this can only get larger or
no smaller because this a that
we're maxing over includes a1.
So we can definitely achieve
at least this value, but it's
possible that some other action will
let us achieve an even larger value.
But by maxing, we can't have
it achieve a smaller value.
I mean it can achieve a smaller value.
But it will at least the max will be
at least as big as what we get from a1.
>> Right.
>> And
with that in place that actually
completes the chain of inequalities from
here to here so we get this non
expansion property for the max operator.
Here the max operator is being used here
as sort of a way of summarizing
these functions F and G.
>> Okay so let me just say that
last thing back to you to make
certain I've got it.
So, I'm with you all the way
to F of A 1 minus G of A 1.
You went to the absolute values sign,
that's pretty easy because you already
knew that value was positive, that
difference was positive by construction.
And then that last step you noticed
that the difference between A1,
F of A1 and G of A1- 1 is some number.
You're maximizing all, over all possible
a's you could stick into f and g.
It has to include a1 by definition,
which means the max might be bigger.
But it couldn't be smaller than the a1,
and so
therefore, you're bounded from above.
>> Excellent.
Good, good, good.
Yeah, well said.
>> That's really cool.
Now I've forgotten why we did this.
>> [LAUGH] I find that's often true for
me as well.
This requires enough of my
attention that I lose context.
But the context was
that we had this step
in our proof that the Bellman
operator is a contraction.
We needed it to be true that summarizing
the Q values at a given state
using a max, was going to leave us with
something that is no farther apart
than the maximum difference between
the two functions that we started with.
>> Okay.
Yeah, I remember that.
Maybe you can show me
the equation again.
>> And in particular, it was this
step right here where, essentially,
we had to, one way to think about it is
move this max out of the absolute value.
So if we compare that to what we just
proved, that that's what we did.
We kind of moved the max
out of the absolute value.
>> Right, that's awesome.
Good.
Okay.
So I get it.
So
the Bellman operator is a contraction
operator value iteration works.
>> Yes indeed.
Now I went through a phase of my
life where I got really fixated on
non-expansion, and identified
a whole bunch of other operators
other than max that
are also non-expansions.
And that actually gives us a way of
analyzing a whole bunch of other kinds
of decision processes.
So not just these standard mark-off
decision properties where we're trying
to maximize expected reward, but
we can do a lot of other things and
this same kind of proof is
going to end up holding.
So we're going to get back to that in
a moment, but first I want to talk about
how we use this property now that we've
established it to prove the convergence
of Q learning, to prove that
this interesting way of updating
the Q values over and over again In
the face of experience actually does,
in the limit, lead you to getting
the solution to the Bellman equation.
>> Okay.